Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Two, Episode Four: general elections, the voting system, how a law is made, and direct democracy.
Free elections are among the most important things in a democracy.
At a general election, the individual voter has influence on which politicians and which political parties are to sit in the Folketing.
Here the voters can express their views on the policy so far, and on the policy they want in the future.
The individual voter has no duty to vote at a general election.
Since the year 2000, between 84 and 88 percent of voters, on average 86 percent, have voted when there has been a general election.
That is a high share compared with most other countries, also Denmark's neighbours.
In Sweden, voter turnout has, by comparison, been 84 percent, in Norway 78 percent, in Germany 76 percent, and in the United Kingdom 65 percent, when there have been elections to those countries' national parliaments since 2000.
In Danish, a general election is a folketingsvalg, a municipal election is a kommunalvalg, and voter turnout is valgdeltagelse.
A general election must be held at least every four years.
This is in the constitution.
The members of the Folketing are thus elected for at most four years at a time, but there is no upper limit to how many times a member can stand for the Folketing and be elected.
It is the prime minister who is responsible for calling a new election before the election period runs out.
That can be after the four years, or earlier, if the prime minister wishes.
General elections are held as general, direct and secret elections.
General means that all persons with Danish citizenship have the right to vote.
They must, however, be eighteen years old, the age of majority, and have a permanent residence in the realm, that is, in Denmark, in Greenland or in the Faroe Islands.
Direct means that you vote directly for the candidates or parties that are standing.
Secret means that you as a voter can freely cast your vote without others being able to see who you vote for.
A person who has the right to vote for the Folketing normally also meets the conditions to be elected to the Folketing.
This is called being eligible, valgbar.
To be eligible, you must among other things have Danish citizenship, be eighteen years old and have a permanent residence in the realm.
But you must not have been punished for something that, in people's eyes, makes you unworthy of sitting in the Folketing.
It is the Folketing that decides whether a convicted member should be regarded as unworthy.
Now the voting system.
If you wish to stand at a general election, you can do it in two ways.
You can stand as a candidate for a party that has the right to take part in the election, a so-called party eligible to stand, which then has to approve you.
This is by far the most common.
All parties that were elected at the last general election are automatically eligible to stand.
For other parties, special rules apply.
For a party to become eligible to stand, it must have collected a certain number of signatures, which must be approved by the Minister of the Interior.
Normally this means about 20,000 signatures.
But you can also stand as a candidate and be elected to the Folketing outside the parties.
Then at least 150 voters in your constituency must sign to say they recommend you, before you can stand.
Very few have been elected in this way.
All eligible voters living in Denmark automatically receive a polling card, a valgkort.
On election day, the citizen can vote in two different ways.
You can vote for a specific politician, a candidate.
This is called a personal vote.
You can also vote for a political party.
This is called a party vote.
You may only put one cross on the ballot paper.
So you cannot vote for several parties or several candidates.
When the votes have been counted, the seats are distributed in the Folketing according to a method decided in advance.
When the general election is over, the elected parties and members negotiate about who should form a government.
All voters can also vote by post in advance of the election, instead of turning up at the polling station and voting on election day itself.
This often happens by showing up at Citizen Service, Borgerservice, in your municipality and casting your vote in an envelope.
But postal votes can also often be cast, for example, in hospitals and nursing homes, where many voters have difficulty getting to the polling stations because of illness or old age.
The Danish election system is arranged so that the composition of the Folketing, as far as possible, reflects who the voters have voted for.
The seats are distributed by the proportional method, forholdstalsmetoden.
That means a political party as far as possible gets the same share of the seats in the Folketing as the party's share of the valid votes cast.
If a party has, for example, received ten percent of the votes, it should, roughly speaking, have ten percent of the seats.
The Danish election system normally requires a party to get at least two percent of the valid votes cast to get into the Folketing.
This so-called electoral threshold, the spærregrænse, is lower than in many neighbouring countries.
In Sweden and Norway it is, for example, four percent, and in Germany five percent.
In practice this means that more parties through the years have been represented in the Folketing in comparison with the parliaments of the neighbouring countries mentioned.
Since 1973, between seven and twelve parties have been elected to the Folketing at each election.
In the Netherlands, for example, there is no electoral threshold, so a party is represented in parliament if it just gets enough votes for a single seat nationwide.
The Dutch parliament has therefore typically had even more parties than the Danish one.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
What share of voters normally vote at elections to the Folketing?
Option A: 60 to 69 percent.
Option B: 70 to 79 percent.
Option C: 80 to 89 percent.
[DA] Hvor stor en andel af vælgerne stemmer normalt ved valg til Folketinget?  A: 60-69 %  |  B: 70-79 %  |  C: 80-89 %
The answer is C: 80 to 89 percent.
It appeared in the June 2020 and November 2025 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: 80-89 %
Question 2.
How many percent of the votes at a general election must a party normally get to enter the Folketing?
Option A: At least 2 percent.
Option B: At least 4 percent.
Option C: At least 6 percent.
[DA] Hvor mange procent af stemmerne ved et folketingsvalg skal et parti normalt have for at komme i Folketinget?  A: Mindst 2 %  |  B: Mindst 4 %  |  C: Mindst 6 %
The answer is A: At least 2 percent.
It appeared in the June 2021 and November 2024 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: Mindst 2 %
Question 3.
How often must there be a general election according to the constitution?
Option A: At least every third year.
Option B: At least every fourth year.
Option C: At least every fifth year.
[DA] Hvor ofte skal der ifølge grundloven være folketingsvalg i Danmark?  A: Mindst hvert tredje år  |  B: Mindst hvert fjerde år  |  C: Mindst hvert femte år
The answer is B: At least every fourth year.
It appeared in the November 2021 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Mindst hvert fjerde år
That's the end of Part One of Episode 4.
In Part Two, we continue with how a law is made, and direct democracy.
See you there.